over the past six months the U.S economy
has changed in more ways than one the
stock market crashed crypto collapsed
and Google searches for recession are at
an all-time high all the signs are
pointing to a painful downturn ahead but
there's still a massive debate unfolding
about whether or not we are actually in
a recession so what's really going on
there's one Gap in the polling data
that's bigger than we've ever seen
before getting raises because of the
inflation but the amount that they're
getting raised is less than the
inflation we're entering the recession
unseen like any other you know the
bottom half of it devastated
we're in a recession
in order to get to the bottom of this I
called up a prominent financial analyst
and content creator named Kyla Scanlon
but before we talk to her it's important
to level set a bit people think a
recession is defined as two or more
consecutive quarters of negative GDP
growth but that's not the only widely
used definition the US government relies
on the National Bureau of economic
research to identify recessions using a
variety of economic indicators they look
at industrial production employment
incomes and trade to get a bigger
picture view of how the economy is doing
and recessions can occur extremely
quickly like in February of 2020 when we
did have a recession but it was
extremely short we're in a recession and
it's not the time to increase taxes or
spending the argument over whether or
not we should call this a recession has
already become politicized the current
political Administration will always
want to paint as Rosie a picture of the
economy as possible but this isn't just
because politicians tend not to get
reelected during recessions promoting
optimism about the economy can actually
lead to more economic growth but we'll
get to that phenomenon later on right
now it's more important to understand
how bad this economic decline is
regardless of what we call it GDP is
falling and that's never good in fact if
we look back through history we can
identify 10 different occasions where
GDP declined for two or more consecutive
quarters and here's the interesting
thing when you look at those 10 periods
dating all the way back to 1949 every
single time GDP dropped for two
consecutive quarters it was eventually
declared a recession so even if we don't
use the two declining quarters metric as
our definition it's clearly a very
strong indicator that a recession is on
the horizon but all this talk of are we
or aren't we in a recession completely
misses the point in my opinion the
bigger question is how bad is this
compared to previous recessions in order
to answer that question I pulled the GDP
numbers for the past 80 years of
recessions to quantify exactly what's
going on and what I found was really
interesting it's down 0.6 percent to be
precise that's actually the smallest
decline going into a recession since
1947. the vast majority of recessions
start with a one two or even three
percent decline in the first six months
but we're doing a lot better right now
this could all change in the future but
right now if we are in a recession it
looks pretty mild but it's not just the
GDP numbers that make today's economic
decline look different from past
recessions it's also important to look
at the employment numbers see when you
look at historical recessions you always
see two things GDP goes down and
unemployment goes up what's weird about
the present day situation is that
unemployment is actually down a lot of
this stems from the fact that
unemployment was so high during the
pandemic that the job market is still in
rebound but overall it's still a good
sign so clearly we're in a weird
situation but perhaps more importantly
what can we do to stop economic Decline
and pump up growth well by now we all
know that inflation is the name of the
game this year prices are going up at
gas stations supermarkets and more so
consumers are clearly feeling that
things are getting rough we're also
starting to see layoffs at a lot of big
companies and there's a general feeling
of anxiety in the air about what comes
next the Federal Reserve has a dual
mandate to try and maximize employment
while ensuring price stability and now
that inflation is spiking the FED has to
step in and try and stabilize prices
without destabilizing the overall
economy so they've been raising interest
rates and reducing the money supply to
try and tame inflation but will it work
well the head of the FED Jerome Powell
has already cautioned and that it will
be challenging to tame inflation without
triggering a recession so it might be
inevitable there is one way to pull out
of this before it's too late though and
in order to understand how to Stave off
recessions we need to go deeper into
what causes them speculative bubbles
Global conflicts worldwide pandemics
these are all common causes of
recessions but there is one common
element between each one they erode
consumer confidence dramatically in 1936
the economist John Maynard Keynes used
the term animal spirits to describe a
collection of instincts and emotions
that guide human behavior the idea is
that a large portion of positive human
activity is the result of spontaneous
optimism rather than some mathematical
expectation as these Animal Spirits rise
humans experience a spontaneous urge to
action rather than inaction this
optimism results in hard work
risk-taking investment and many more
activities that set the stage for
economic growth when everyone is
optimistic about the future we
collectively work to make that imagined
future a reality but unfortunately this
also works in the opposite direction as
well when everyone expects that a
collapse is inevitable they pull back on
everything consumers buy less goods and
services factories reduce production
capacity companies lay off workers and
everything slows down Animal Spirits can
feed off themselves and create frenzies
so the government typically tries to
step in during moments of Crisis and set
the stage the goal is to allow the
creativity of capitalism to flourish but
also curtail excesses that occur because
of our Animal Spirits confidence isn't
strictly limited to expectations about
the economy though it goes deeper Animal
Spirits refers also to the sense of
trust humans have in each other if
there's a sense of fairness in economic
dealings everyone is more likely to
collaborate effectively during difficult
Economic Times it's critical that people
understand how our Collective emotions
affect the economy financial analyst
Kyla Scanlon has done a fantastic job of
popularizing this idea with a new twist
she recently argued that we are
currently in a Vibe session which makes
a lot of sense when you think about it
the unemployment data might still be
strong and it's possible that the FED
tames inflation without causing
recession but clearly The Vibes are
totally off right now there are so many
different economic problems to Grapple
with but there's also a big disconnect
between the reality of what's going on
and the current Vibes I wanted to go
deeper into all of this so I called up
Kyla to help sort this out I wanted to
talk to you specifically about the vibe
session piece you put together so could
you just give me kind of your overview
of what your thesis was with that piece
and and maybe if anything's changed
since then what you're what you're
feeling on it is currently yeah yeah um
so that piece was basically like we're
not in a recession according to the
economic data but it sure feels like
we're in one and that was the whole
point of like a Vibe session like The
Vibes are off right and so like we have
a recession in Vibes so that was the
whole point of the piece just talking
about like you know jobs are relatively
okay of course inflation is Raging but
you know everything else is doing decent
things are not horrible but it doesn't
feel good right and like especially if
you say that out loud to people who are
struggling with inflation and struggling
to afford groceries rent Etc
um it can be you know it's like yelling
at somebody in a hole that you know at
least you haven't hit the bottom of the
hole yet uh so that's that's part of the
problem but yeah that was the whole
pieces of the piece and I do think that
the economic data has worsened since I
read that so I wrote it very recently
like a month ago maybe
um but I do think like now we're
starting to see a downturn in the
metrics we have a print in the GDP next
week which will tell us if we're in a
technical recession or not not a
recession but just technical so yeah
lots of interesting things coming and
the definition for technical recession
is two quarters yeah
the odors of declining G Ang
which is not an eer is a group that
actually decides if we're in a recession
and they look at more than just GDP
right yeah yeah so a lot of this comes
back to I mean if there is a recession I
think a lot of people will lay it at the
at the hands of the FED
um so can you talk a little bit about
how you view what the FED is working on
kind of their dual mandate and and like
why they're doing the things that
they're doing I guess yeah yeah so their
dual mandate as priceability and maximum
employment which are very hard to
achieve right like how do you achieve
both of those things at the same time
um and so I think like this is an
unpopular opinion and I get yelled at
all the time for it but like I think
they're doing the best that they can
um and the best that they can is not
good so I think that's an important
point to make like the best that they
are they can do right now is not it's
not good
um so I think they're trying their best
like they're going to probably raise
rates they have another meeting
um next week and they're probably going
to reduce Race by 75 basis points but
the question is like is them doing this
sort of monetary policy going to be
enough right to sort of stem the
inflation that we're seeing which is
largely coming from Energy prices and
raising race is not going to pump more
oil out of the ground you know it
doesn't really work like that so I think
the FED is doing the best that they can
with the tools that they have but we
really need to see like fiscal policy
like the governments step in and do
something that they're you know
gridlocked so yeah I I heard an
interesting uh interview with someone
who worked at the fed and they said that
one of the problems like you saw this
when the recession warning started
happening on Twitter a lot of people
were kind of inflation Hawks like nine
months ago or a year ago and saying like
we're seeing inflation like why isn't
the FED doing anything why isn't the FED
doing anything there's this Theory at
the FED that you shouldn't step on the
gas and the break at the same time and
in general if you're expanding the
balance sheet you shouldn't really be
raising interest rates at the same time
right so so the thought was well forward
guidance is a very powerful
tool in the tool kit for the fed and
they've given this forward guidance
about about balance sheet activity so
they couldn't really act any sooner
because that would invalidate their
previous forward guidance and they have
to maintain some level of credibility
there's this interesting element where
the FED seems to act a little bit slower
than some people might like but the
alternative might actually be worse
which is I think a little bit of what
you're highlighting I just wanted to
know if uh if you if you thought about
that like stepping on the gas and the
brake like that being a very because I
think that's happening in the EU right
now there's a little bit of like they're
still expanding the balance sheet while
raising interest rates and it sends a
very confusing signal to the market
whereas in the US we've actually the
money supply is actually decreasing
right now and interest rates are rising
which is a very logical action for the
FED to take but it's I just wanted to
know if you had thought anything about
like the role of forward guidance in
what the FED is doing yeah I knew
absolutely I think there's a couple of
like to the point of like why did the
FED not address inflation
um the forward guidance was a big part
of that but also they did not have
leadership Clarity like Jerome Powell
did not know if he was going to be in
charge of the fed and so like that
prevented them from moving as it
quarrels or any quarrels who was on the
FED actually spoke about that um a few
months ago and basically like he was
like yeah we didn't know it was he was
going to be in charge like it's really
hard to make policy if you don't know
who's going to be in charge
um because like the different people
would handle it different ways um so I
think that's an important point and then
in terms of like credibility and forward
guidance like yeah that the reason that
the Federal Reserve members come out and
speak so much is because they're trying
to maintain that credibility trying to
make sure that people are like okay yes
we do believe that the FED is saying
these things and that even if they don't
do these things like it's still going to
make that impact on the market
um and the FED also moved really slow
because like there was uncertainty
around the labor market to the point of
forward guidance like they were like we
really need to make sure that maximum
employment is still going to be like an
important part of what we're doing and
so that just really compounded and them
moving slow and now it's really this um
how do they maintain credibility and
that involves them speaking out so much
and yeah just sticking yeah so in terms
of the pandemic what do you think was
like how do you think the inflation like
actually played out there and was there
anything that the that the government
could have done sooner to kind of avoid
that
from happening yeah yeah like the supply
chains and like having just in time
um it became really apparent that that
is a very fragile system and if you
don't have like the labor that needed or
if you don't have the boats going at the
same like the time that they need to be
going all of a sudden everything begins
to break down so I think Supply chains
and the breakdown that came from that
because of the pandemic or just a huge
driver of inflation and it's relative I
think it's actually underappreciated
even though we talk about it a lot I
think it's very important because like
we got really used to like the Amazon
effect where we could order whatever
whatever and so like there is the
numerical aspect of that inflation but
then also the qualitative aspects the
quantitative qualitative so the
qualitative is like oh I can't get
things as fast as I used to their
shortages and that to the point about
consumer sentiment expectations that
we're talking about earlier
um that sort of compounds the
insulationary feeling even more yeah
yeah it's interesting like I wonder what
would have happened if if they'd raised
rates
earlier
I mean it seems like it would it would
have just hurt GDP much more and and
kind of limited the recovery there's
been a lot of really good articles
recently about capital investment in the
lack thereof that we've had in the
United States so like companies are
preferring to buy back shares versus
invest in the infrastructure right and
same with the United States like the
government like there's not a whole lot
of investment even though we have
infrastructure bill
um so I think like that's part of the
problem is that we just have under
invested in these very important things
like supply chain so it's not a question
of can the FED raise and fix this it's
like how can we make it better right
yeah yeah yeah yeah it doesn't really
help if you raise rates and then and
then companies buy back shares or
something and then what was your view on
the the Russian invasion of Ukraine uh
yeah I mean not cause an energy crisis
in Europe right and also a food shortage
it's really created a lot of issues so
like Russia has a huge energy supplier
to Europe and if you invade your
neighbor all of a sudden like that
energy is not going to be as stable as
it was and you don't want to use that
energy as much distinctions Etc so I
think like that has been really
inflationary especially in Europe and
then for food like if you look at
Emerging Market Nations a lot of
countries were reliant on Ukraine for
wheat and Russia for meat and that's
just not been a stable so like there's
all these dominoes that are sort of
tipping because of that war and then
Supply chains right like the boats not
being able to exit Ukraine
um Ukraine is I think like the fifth
largest producer of Wheat and that goes
everywhere so it's it's really it's
really impactful we I think we've seen
Energy prices kind of ticked down
recently is that correct yeah
um so so what do you attribute that to
uh so oil is kind of funky right so the
oil's gone down a little bit and that's
because of recession worries apparently
really uh you know there's an idea that
OPEC is going to start to produce more
Biden just visited Saudi Arabia and
the conclusion is that they'll hopefully
produce more but I think that the way
that it's trading right now is because
people are thinking that we're going to
go into recession people are going to
use less oil they're going to use less
gasoline so it's kind of that Domino
yeah yeah that makes sense and then I I
want to talk about home shortages
specifically I mean that is one of the
that is one of the items where there's
there's always this question about like
is this generation worse off than the
previous generation and housing is kind
of the first thing that people point to
but I'm wondering what's like like let's
start with what your explanation is for
the kind of decline in home ownership
amongst the millennial gen Z generation
versus like the boomer generation well
it's a play yeah so like the members are
still in the homes um and there's not
more homes for people to buy so I think
that's a big problem and I also think
like there is to your point about like
maybe like lack of affordability home
prices are up like 50 and over the past
two years so people Millennials that are
trying to move into suburbs like you
know get out of the city have kids
whatever that is not like you can't work
you can't work a nine to five and afford
a house anymore to a certain extent it's
some of these places
um so I think that's part of the problem
too it's just affordability and support
them so I I want to talk a little bit
about your work kind of popularizing
these a little bit more Arcane economic
Concepts so do you think about that when
you're writing do you think about like
okay I have there might be a technical
term for something that's going on that
I'm observing but I kind of need to
reframe this for a specific audience
um so how do you think about like your
your creation process essentially uh
yeah I mean like there's different like
I create a lot of different content so
YouTube newsletter and Tick Tock all
sort of like require well YouTube in the
newsletter sort of thing but like it all
requires a different way of like
approaching it so for tick tock it's
like how fast can I explain something I
only have 60 seconds to like explain
relatively dense Concepts so it's really
a combination of just explaining things
in the simplest way possible
um sort of repeating myself quite a bit
and using visuals on screen to if
there's like if it is a little bit more
complicated to like help aid in that
um so yeah that's really the main thing
is like how can I explain this in a way
that like a five-year-old would
understand even though five-year-olds
aren't watching myself you know it's
just like yeah as possible yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that makes sense are
there any other
um kind of economic Concepts that you
haven't quite cracked how to popularize
uh man um I don't know so like my most
recent video was about the money supply
not being the driver of inflation oh
yeah yeah that was like a very
controversial and I think that's like a
very interesting one to kind of keep on
pushing on like these different schools
of thoughts like Keynes versus uh
Friedman like all these different things
like how do you sort of think about
economic theory and then also economic
practice because those are two very
different things
um so I think that's the biggest thing
is like people
helping the helping uh and I need help
with this too but like there's Nuance to
this stuff it's not always going to be
one big thing driving everything like
that is way too reductive how are you
thinking about the downturn I mean it
seems like it seems very technical at
this perspective like it seems very
um like almost moderated by the fed and
it seems like a voluntary recession if
anything
um it I mean maybe you could make the
argument that it's kind of like this
delayed hangover payment for all of the
previous crisis crises that we've fought
off with monetary policy and now we're
kind of paying that debt down
um but but how are you thinking about it
are you thinking about it like you know
this is 2008 or this is 2001 or this is
you know are you looking to history or
are you uh looking to something else
yeah I mean this is not 2008 in my mind
uh I think this time around there's a
lot more dominoes that are pretty
concerning so like what's going on in
Europe is really worrying so the ECB
just raised their rates by 50 basis
points and Italy is about to implode
essentially in like Germany their
spreads are widening and so there's a
lot of flashing red bells over in Europe
there's a lot of flashing bells in Japan
right like there again is just cratering
and they're hanging on to GUI for dear
life and the FED is sort of like the
pillar of the rest of the central banks
and so what I'm really worried about is
the Fed is going to have to go and kind
of like save other central banks and
that will prevent them from fully
executing on monetary policy here in the
United States I don't know if there's
been another scenario kind of like that
um obviously like Europe and there's
been little they'll answer help before
like the European debt crisis um so I
think like it's happened but yeah this
time around there's just a lot of
flashing red bells with dead and I think
that sure is it's not like houses or
consumers it's like corporations yeah
yeah when when the when the pandemic hit
I looked back to there's a great
presentation by Sequoia Capital uh
called like the Black Swan memo or rip
good times was the first version that
they put out and they and they they put
this out to all their portfolio
companies at the start of the the
housing crash and they looked at like a
whole bunch of different economic
factors like the strength of the
household balance sheet and they
basically told the story that like the
average American swimmer is way over
leveraged they're underwater on their
mortgages like this is going to lead to
a pretty severe recession and they were
right A lot of people were saying this
at the time
um and then when when covet hit I looked
at the same I looked at all the same
metrics and the health of the American
Consumer was a lot stronger it's a
little bit weaker now but in general a
lot of the fiscal stimulus it seems like
that's actually shored up the average
Americans balance sheet so the the
American Consumer isn't in as much of a
rough position but we're in this very
odd place where we have you know
solid employment numbers we have
inflation but people have money they're
not entirely broke but there's a lot of
you know different contagion risks all
over the world in these like kind of
Niche pockets of financial assets where
if it starts bleeding over it could be
really bad yeah I know I think it's like
yeah it's definitely not as consumer
driven this time around like consumers
are doing relatively okay uh you know
their credit card debt is ticking up but
it's not like 2008 where everybody had a
mortgage right you know it's not a
mortgage that they should have been
having
um so I think it's definitely like this
time around like you're starting to see
ghost companies I think you're starting
to see it especially like in BC land
where yes these Mega funded companies
that are now having Mass layoffs and I
think that is sort of a predecessor for
public markets yeah yeah it's always
interesting to look at the the size of
these relative to like the size of the
asset class relative to the amount of
like press it gets right yeah crypto
massive press attention but at the end
of the day it was like a one or two
trillion dollar market and yeah it's
sold off and there were a couple like
really really bad blow-ups but I was
always as the crypto run-up was
happening I was always talking to my
friends who were really into it kind of
trying to get a feel for the contagion
effect if it didn't go well like and and
when they broke down like oh yeah defy
it's great you just like get this wallet
and then go here and then go to uniswap
and do this I was like yeah I'm not
really worried about the average
American grandmother getting wrapped up
in that like maybe they bought some
Bitcoin but like I don't think that
they're you know in some I don't think
they're in three arrows capital or you
know Luna or something so it doesn't
seem like that would have a major
contagion effect and it doesn't seem
like it has which is good but obviously
there are other asset classes is that
could have a much wider you know
contagion effect like the government
debt that you mentioned
um yeah it's just very interesting to
look at these like I don't think there's
there's very much uh attention paid to
like you know Japanese government debt
in the American Media versus like crypto
thanks for watching I highly recommend
following Kyla her content is super
balanced and fast-paced so you can
quickly stay up to date with what's
going on in the economy I'll leave links
to her accounts in the description below
thanks for watching